- Everyone, welcome,
welcome, welcome, welcome
into another edition of Market Takes.
We are looking out at all the things
that you need to be
looking out for this week,
all the big things coming up,
and it's not just economic data this week.
We've got a couple big
things coming up this week
that you're gonna wanna look out for
that aren't just releases
from the government or
statistical agencies.
First of all, starting at
3:00 AM Tuesday morning,
that is tomorrow,
you've got the start of Amazon Prime Day.
I'm gonna tell you why
you're gonna wanna look out
for Amazon Prime Day and
why that could move markets
and why that'll be important
for the economy in just a minute.
Also, of course, it is CPI week.
We got the Consumer Price Index
coming out on Wednesday morning.
We'll be right here on Market
Takes breaking all that down.
And then on Friday we have
the start of earning season,
the unofficial start of big earning season
with those big banks.
You've got Citigroup,
JPMorgan, Wells Fargo,
all coming out on Friday.
We're gonna dive into
why that'll be important
for this week.
So first things first, let's
start with Amazon Prime Day.
That kicks off tomorrow morning, 3:00 AM.
It's gonna be July 11th and 12th.
What it is?
Amazon Prime Day is just a big day
where Amazon offers a lot of big discounts
for its Prime members.
They pay about $15 a month.
And if you are a member of
the, you know, the Prime group,
if you subscribe to Amazon Prime,
you get big discounts on Amazon,
really a lot of tech items,
a lot of things that
have really, you know,
been marked down significantly
and that's designed to
bump up those sales.
This has been a really big event,
I don't wanna say a big day,
because over the past few years,
Amazon has stretched Prime
Day into a couple days
as they'll be doing this year,
but over $10 billion in sales,
so say, you know, consumer reports
about Amazon Prime Day
over the last couple times.
Now, we've got this year coming up,
a lot of other retailers have
actually joined into this,
and so this has become not
just a thing about Amazon,
but you've got Target
launching Target Circle members
having their Target Circle day.
That was starting July 9th.
You've also had, in previous years,
Walmart has joined in with
their Walmart+ programs.
So you've got some of
the biggest retailers
all across the board joining
in on this big sales day.
And this makes this not just about Amazon,
but about consumer sales,
about online retail sales,
about the pickup or
attempt to really jumpstart
and jolt higher some of those sales
that have been consistently kind of lower
in the summer months.
So this started back in 2015
and, historically, had been
the week after July 4th,
but in 2020, Prime Day
was moved to October,
and in 2021, it was also
in June and October.
Now it's back to being in July.
And we are gonna see just
how much timing matters
and how much this can really jolt up
those retail sales of goods
which have been lagging.
Wanna put something up here
on your screen right now,
and that is just the
chart of US retail sales.
This is the change that we
have seen year over year.
Going back now, if you look in 2023,
the start of 2023 in January,
and then coming into what
we're seeing last month,
you've just seen a
pretty consistent decline
in terms of the overall
percentage change in retail sales.
Those sales have been coming
down pretty consistently,
going back all the way to about mid 2022.
Now we have seen inflation
has come down as well,
but we know really big price increases
were jolting those numbers higher,
and now we have seen a declining number,
especially when you break out
the good side of those
retail sales numbers,
those numbers have been coming down,
and that chart really just
illustrating the slowdown
that we have seen in retail sales,
and that's why Amazon Prime
Day coming up here in July
could be a big deal.
Again, you've also got
Target participating,
you likely have Walmart participating,
and we know consumers have
been spending a lot more
on services going out to
bars, restaurants, barbers,
things like that, rather than goods,
things that they purchase on amazon.com
or Walmart or any of those.
So this will be a good
test of the economy.
Is the good sector, can the
good sector really pick up
and repeat some of those big numbers
that we had seen for Amazon
Prime Day in the past?
Now, what we also know about consumers,
consumers have been
loading up credit cards.
They haven't really been buying with cash
or buying with debit cards,
using that money straight
from their account.
They've been borrowing money essentially,
taking out those personal loans.
Consumer credit card
debt is at a record high,
and we also see that while
consumer credit card rates
are at record high.
So we know folks are paying a
lot more to borrow that money
from the banks in the
form of credit cards.
Will that continue and will
they keep doing that to splurge
on something like Prime Day?
You know, this isn't the thing
where we've seen
consumers really switching
more to necessities, more
to things like groceries,
more to things like gas, and
then spending their money there
rather than on those big purchases
from Amazon and other retailers.
Are they gonna continue to do that
for something like sales with Amazon,
and we'll see if that continues.
So another big test to the economy,
can this trend we've seen
of folks loading up those credit cards
and spending that money continue
for something, you know,
it's not really about needs,
this is more about wants,
about tech items, about VR headsets,
and things like that, speakers,
and all those kind of smart devices,
will that motivate folks to keep spending?
This could also be a
really interesting test
for the health of the economy.
We will see that consumer credit data,
that's out today at three
o'clock, but it is for May.
So it's a couple months delayed,
but that is gonna be a good test
for the overall health of the economy.
Do consumers keep spending as they have?
We have seen retail sales,
as we just showed you on the
screen, come down for a bit.
One caveat to this Amazon Prime Day,
because, again, this could
move stocks, this, you know,
if it breaks the pattern that we have seen
of lower retail sales,
of lower good sales,
that could really push stocks higher.
If the numbers are disappointing,
that could move stocks lower,
and this could be something
that moves the market,
so you're gonna wanna look out for that.
One caveat, like I said,
is that there isn't
really an official metric.
Amazon doesn't put out their numbers.
Last year, for example,
rather than disclose the total
number of sales, they said,
"Amazon Prime members saved $1.7 billion
more than any other Prime Day."
Well, that doesn't tell us
how much they spent, right?
It doesn't tell us how much
actual revenue was drawn.
It doesn't tell us how
much profit was made.
It just kind of tells us,
"Okay, well they saved
a lot of money. Great."
Independent analysts, though,
like Digital Commerce 360 and Adobe,
they provide some estimates
and some info and some intel
so we can get an idea for what happened.
So you wanna look out for those reports
and those could move markets.
Second thing we wanna talk about this week
is CPI inflation data.
I wanna throw up here on your screen
just the trend that we have seen from CPI.
Now, what you see there
is a consistent decline
in the year-over-year inflation rate.
We have seen 11 straight months
of declining CPI, of declining inflation,
and that is definitely
what the Fed wants to see.
So that chart up there on your screen
illustrating the trend that
we have seen for a while,
going back about a year in CPI,
and, you know, we have seen
just a decline in inflation.
That's a good thing.
You know, those prices
have been coming down
since the Fed has been acting.
Now, the big question is,
could we see CPI rise again?
And the answer is yes.
However, economists are expecting
a very bullish reading for June.
Economists expect to see
if inflation decline to 3.1% on the CPI.
Now, that would be huge
because it would bring
CPI down much closer
to the Fed's target range.
A lot of folks think that, you know,
the Fed would actually be
okay with 3% inflation,
a lot of folks think
the FedEx should actually
be targeting 3% inflation.
So if we get that 3% number,
that would be really big
and that would be important.
Now, here's why we could
see an increase in CPI.
We have seen services
spending continuing to rise,
even coming into this last month.
The last few months we've seen
services spending pick up.
Core CPI has not been declining
as it had been previously.
We've also seen housing prices
pick up significantly lately,
and that is the biggest component of CPI.
Of course, the Fed's favorite metric, CPI,
declined in June, but did pick up in May.
So we could see that kind of transfer into
or translate into what
we see on the CPI report.
Now, the CPI report could move the market
in a number of ways, even
though if we get that 3% number
that would be bullish
overall for the market,
could see stocks really take off,
but that could push bond yields up higher
as folks sell out of those bonds and say,
"Hey, the stock market's
gonna start taking off.
I don't wanna own bonds anymore.
I want to own stocks so that
I can make a lot more money."
Well, that could push bond
yields up, because as we know,
when folks sell bonds, the prices decline,
the rates, the yields rise,
and that could again make
those more attractive
and kind of create this
inverse correlation
between stocks and bonds,
and you could actually say
that hurt the stock market.
So a lot of interesting
things to break down on CPI.
We will be right here on Market Takes
breaking that down for you on Wednesday.
Last thing we wanna
talk about for this week
is those bank earnings
that we got out on Friday.
I wanna throw us chart
here up on your screen
to just show you how the stock
market has been performing.
As you see that light blue line
up there, that's the NASDAQ,
the dark blue line, that's the S&P 500.
Overall, the market so far
this year really since March
has been kicked into high gear.
But those bank stocks,
you see the green line,
the white line, the red
line there on your screen
have really underperformed,
and that just illustrates
that bank stocks,
even the big ones,
even though they weren't the ones affected
by what happened with
those regional banks,
they have really
continued to underperform.
Now, if we get another big
blowout earnings release,
from the second quarter earnings reports
that we see on Friday,
this could move the market significantly
because bank stocks have really been
one of the big underperformers
for the market.
If, on the other hand,
bank earnings disappoint,
which folks aren't really
expecting right now,
they expect the banks to do pretty well,
but that could pull the market back down,
kind of snap us maybe out of
this high that we've been on
where the NASDAQ up 30%
so far a year to date,
the S&P 500 up more than 12%,
up around that 13% number,
that could snap us out.
Here's what to look for.
With JPMorgan Chase, that is
the biggest bank in the US,
more than 60 million customers,
it's gonna tell us a lot
about the US consumer.
How much your consumer spending
on debit versus credit cards?
Are we still seeing a big
pickup in credit card borrowing?
Are they spending more on debit?
How did JPMorgan do
after the ridiculous earnings
quarter they had in Q1,
12.6 billion in profits,
38.3 billion in revenue?
Are they able to replicate
that, keep that party going,
or did things pull back
in the second quarter?
With Citi, how much loan loss
provisions did they put away?
Are banks really convinced
that this soft landing can
happen, or are they worried?
Are they saying, "We
gotta put some money away
because we're worried that people
aren't gonna be paying back those loans
they've taken out from us"?
And is deal making back?
We have seen a lot of the
data saying, "No, it's not."
Banks are hurting a little bit,
so we'll see how Citi responds to that.
Wells Fargo, they also
had a big first quarter,
increased profit by 30%,
increased net interest
income by around 45%.
Are they able to replicate that?
Analysts are expecting some big numbers
from the stock market,
and we're gonna see if that can continue.
So we're gonna get out of here,
but, again, what to
watch out for this week?
Amazon Prime Day over
the next couple days.
CPI on Wednesday will be
right here on Market Takes
10:00 AM Eastern time.
We'll hope you'll join us.
And then those big bank
earnings on Friday.
And listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on Market Takes.
I am Dion Rabouin, Reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
We'll be here Wednesday morning
10:00 AM doing Market Takes.
Hope you'll be with us and join
us when we do it next time.